welcome back to las vegas now one local
company is all about protecting
communities
and stopping the spread of cobit 19. i
went into the lab with proactive
sanitizing to test out their new product
and the proof is in the numbers take a
look
the main reason we dove into proactive
sanitizing was because of covid19
we wanted to help businesses reopen and
protect all people working
with inside of businesses or in homes
from bacterias
it's really incredible for us to have
the log seven kill
in an ecological product that also has a
broad spectrum of kill it kills
every pathogen there's nothing left out
the covet 19 virus
is actually one of the easiest things
for this product to neutralize
the covid virus is a small bit of
protein
encased in a little bit of fat this
product dissolves the fat
neutralizes the protein in about 15
seconds it's a very very fast and easy
kill
sanitation just incredible
and because it's so new that's why you
don't know about it that's what we're
here today
to tell everybody about we can work with
them by
sanitizing their spaces for them
we can train them to sanitize their own
spaces so the first thing we're going to
do is going to do a little test with
some raw chicken that we have here on
the plate
we're going to swish it around the plate
clean it off and do a little test with a
hygiena system sure plus tester
which tests atp the building block of
life and let you know if there's any
biologicals on the plate
and i think everybody would agree that
raw chicken supposedly has the most
nasty things on it so we're just going
to put it on the plate like that
and just wipe some of that off dry and
it's just picking up the germs
it's just picking up the germs and then
it's going to read the germs the test
tube goes
into the machine keep in mind the way
this works
a reading of one to ten is hospital
grade sanitized clean
10 to 30 is clean enough for a
restaurant
over 30 you should probably start
cleaning
we've got a reading of 1166. the x means
you have failed
this is a dirty plate but we knew that
it's raw chicken now we're going to see
if we can clean it
and get a better result all right
so you're spraying on your product now
yes
now this product that we said has to be
a and b mixed together
so this is a and b mixed together and
it's been on there for a couple seconds
i'm going to go ahead and wipe it off
we don't need a 60 second or two minute
or 10 minute sit time
rocky would you like to do the test yeah
all right you're a scientist come on in
all right i've got my lab coat on that's
right you do just a little pattern this
way and then a pattern the other way and
twirl it around a little bit you want to
get everything on there
all right now back into the test tube
bend and send it over
there you go i heard it snap that's good
all right dr
rocky yeah i put that right into the
device close the top
and then we have to push
okay yep there you go it's counting down
ten ten that's hospital room clean so we
have an atomizer and what we do is we
take our part b
and part a of the product we mix those
together
and then we do what we call fogging so
as we fog the area it immediately cleans
it
leaving it hospital grade clean and you
were able to re-enter the room within 30
minutes
i think you're certified i'm officially
certified
nice work thanks frank
for more information call proactive
sanitizing at 702-326-9818 or just visit
their website at proactivesanitizing.com
don't forget they have an exclusive
channel 8 special offer for you
you get a free hygienist testing with
service and that's usually 150
so that's a great bargain all and all
you have to do is mention las vegas now
and that's it you get a special offer
we'll be right back